what's going on guys this is rob and
with the newest eternals trailer giving
us our first real look at the celestials
in the mcu which by the way i think they
look fantastic i thought it'd be a great
time to make an origins and powers video
on the celestials themselves you could
have at least some idea of what to
expect going into the mcu after all we
may not see an exact duplication of
their powers or origins from the comics
in the mcu but at the very least you'd
be able to keep up with everybody else's
conversations when they're talking about
things so here is the origin of the
celestials wind the clock back to before
the multiverse before anything and all
you had was the one above all now the
one above all was in effect god in
marvel comics right and still is right
he's this immutable indestructible force
and what the one above all had done as
its first real foray into creating life
was to create the first firmament also
known as the first universe the idea
here was that the first universe was
basically autonomous it could do
whatever it wanted to do but it was
lonely and so what it did was basically
create children and so you can kind of
think of the first universe as a kind of
sentience of a universe itself basically
like a giant empty chasm and so in
creating its children which it called
the aspirants what they started doing
was creating things to fill this
universal space solar systems and
galaxies and stars and different things
like that now the way this worked is
that the aspirants whenever they created
a thing a planet life on that planet
stars galaxies whatever they would
approach the first universe and they
would ask its permission or ask if it
was satisfied with what they'd done and
if the first universe was happy with
their creation then their creation would
continue on to its eventual end whatever
that end happened to be right an
asteroid hitting a planet and the planet
gets destroyed a galaxy being sucked
into a supermassive black hole at its
center doesn't really matter but if the
first universe said it was unhappy with
their creation the aspirants would
destroy what they created and then start
over again now while that whole process
was going on there was actually a
faction of aspirants that didn't believe
the first universe was perfect in its
form that it actually felt like life
including the universe itself as well as
themselves should understand growth
change and mortality basically meaning
they should experience dying and being
reborn as something different than what
they were before and so as a result of
this two things happen the first is that
these rebels cast off their name aspirin
and instead started calling themselves
celestials the second thing that
happened is that they were branded
heretics by the first universe and this
led to a holy war between the celestials
and the aspirants themselves now this
holy war was massive in scale as you
would expect with a war between two
races both of which have the ability to
alter reality on its most fundamental
scale right to alter the very fabric of
the universe itself it was pretty big
this actually led to the aspirants
creating something called the god killer
armor which was like this 25 000 foot
tall armor that was used by the
aspirants to literally hunt down and
destroy celestials now for reasons that
are never really given to us what we end
up finding out is that the aspirants had
essentially
gotten themselves involved in a civil
war and that what the celestials had
done is they had used that opportunity
to basically capitalize and destroy the
aspirants the second thing they did is
they detonated what amounted to a cosmic
bomb and when it went off it essentially
shattered the first universe into an
infinite number of pieces and that's
where the first multiverse comes from
and so following that with the the
aspirants dead the first universe
essentially now becoming the first
multiverse this led to the celestials
essentially duplicating themselves and
then spreading throughout the entirety
of the multiverse and that's why you
have celestials in every universe
throughout the whole multiverse and
they're all basically duplicates of each
other because they are in effect
duplicates they made copies and just
kind of sent themselves forward now
having said all of that what's the power
of the celestials and as a bonus
question what do celestials do okay the
power of the celestials is basically
infinite they can do anything they want
to these guys have the power to create
life to destroy life presumably to
resurrect the dead they have the power
to alter reality on a cosmic scale they
can do basically anything they want to
the funny thing is you don't really see
it all that often in marvel comics
instead the power of the celestials is
relegated to the roles they play in
marvel comics now there are a couple
caveats for example tiamu the dreaming
celestial is probably the most powerful
of all the celestials this dude's so
powerful that like the cosmic entities
are even afraid of them right like
galactus we know is afraid of them
presumably the other cosmic entities are
afraid of them the watcher who sees
everything couldn't see the dreaming
celestial when he woke up i mean this
guy is just it's absurd how powerful the
dreaming celestial is but he's quite
literally dreaming he's unconscious and
he's just been on earth for a really
long time hopefully we'll see him in the
mcu with regards to the other celestials
and this is something that's
particularly interesting because a lot
of people ask about that this guy is
named ereshim the judge the whole idea
behind irish and the judge is part and
parcel to the bigger role that the
celestials play so the idea is that
while the celestials can basically do
anything they want to what they've
chosen to do is basically shepherd the
evolutionary process of sentient beings
across the whole universe what does that
mean it basically means they travel from
planet to planet experimenting on life
and then watching those experiments
unfold the way this works and we can use
earth as an example since it's something
that we talked about in our previous
video as well as kind of reiterating
here is that the celestials showed up on
earth at a previous point in time they
modified the genes of early man which
led to the deviants the eternals and
then the eventual development of the
mutant gene which gave us mutants in
marvel comics the celestials after
conducting that original experiment left
earth to go do whatever it is they were
going to do they eventually returned a
few more times and that's what they do
now with earth it was a little bit
different because there were some
situations unfolding that required their
attention here like when the deviants
enslaved humanity when you had the sky
fathers so like zeus and odin and those
guys who were getting involved in the
affairs of mortal men and altering the
potential destiny of humanity as the
celestials originally wanted to see it
unfold under any normal circumstance
they never would have shown back up but
because of those things they had to get
involved but what the celestials would
normally do is they would conduct their
experiment on a world then they'll leave
then they'll come back and they'll judge
that experiment now the judgment process
is upheld by somebody called irishm the
judge and ereshim will basically show up
and he'll analyze the experiment analyze
basically the world and if he judges in
favor of it the world just continues on
and everything's fine if ereshim judges
against the world then the world is
completely sanitized and when i say
sanitized i mean completely cleansed all
life on that world is completely and
totally eradicated and then following
that the celestial gardeners will step
in and they'll start the process of
seeding life on that world and then the
entire experimentation process will
begin again and the celestials will
leave then they'll come back and they'll
judge it again right this is kind of how
that whole thing works that's the role
they play in the universe but despite
that being their role they're immensely
powerful and there's multiple instances
when you can look at marvel comics and
get a good idea of how powerful they are
now the question you guys are
undoubtedly going to be asking and that
other people are going to be asking here
is how does the power of the celestials
compare to the power of an infinity
gauntlet okay this is probably going to
be the most popular question anybody's
going to ask the celestials
are not necessarily equal to the power
of an infinity gauntlet but they kind of
are it's a weird situation so when you
look at what the celestials do they they
modify and they alter the fabric of the
universe right it's like picking up a
pen and writing on paper that's really
all it is when it comes to something
like the infinity gauntlet it makes you
one with the universe so it's like you
are the pin and you are the paper right
uh it really allows a far more nuanced
scale more specifically than that in
terms of how marvel explains it it's
just a hierarchy right having the
infinity gauntlet makes you more
powerful than a celestial we know that
because when thanos had the infinity
gauntlet in the original infinity
gauntlet story the celestials couldn't
overpower him in fact nobody could not
even eternity the walking talking
embodiment of the universe itself
could not overpower thanos so the
infinity gauntlet is basically top tier
when it comes to any one particular
universe i personally think the cosmic
cube is as well just because the cosmic
cube is basically a wishing box so you
can do anything you want with it as long
as you possess a cosmic cube you can
define the laws of physics you can do
all kinds of crazy things but for their
power the the celestials are basically
just these wildly powerful beings right
there's nothing they cannot do there's
nothing beyond their ability to achieve
because of the power they possess if you
can imagine it they can do it that's
just the kind of power they have the
biggest issue is you don't really see
them using that power because that's not
the role they play in the universe it's
like galactus right the role of galactus
is to basically maintain universal
balance by traveling from world of world
that's life-sustaining and consuming
that world thereby destroying it and
most likely eradicating all the people
on it but just because galactus does
that does not mean that he's not wildly
powerful he's insanely powerful you just
don't really see him using his power on
that level very often and indeed that's
from most of the cosmic entities you see
in marvel comics eon eternity infinity
the in-betweener a lot of these guys
right they have insane levels of power
you just don't really see them use that
power all that often one because it
probably wouldn't make for a very
compelling story and two because they
just don't really need to if we're being
honest with ourselves though when it
comes to these things the infinity
gauntlet the celestials eternity
infinity these cosmic entities like
galactus and all that kind of stuff
their level of power is so extreme there
might as well not be any differentiation
i mean sure technically the infinity
gauntlet is more powerful than a
celestial but when you're talking about
the ability to warp or alter reality on
a universal scale to manipulate time to
scan and control the thoughts of all
beings in existence to literally reshape
reality as you see fit there really is
no differentiation there i guess the big
difference is that the infinity gauntlet
can alter reality harder than the
celestials can
i don't know i don't really know how you
justify that
but marvel does they give us a kind of
hierarchy and just sort of go forward
from there with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end if you
guys are looking for a more
comprehensive explanation about the
celestials something that will give you
a ton of information way more than i
gave you here make sure you guys check
out the link down in the description
it'll take you to my celestials
explained video over at comics explain
where i will make you an expert on the
the race group team whatever you want to
call them in the span of about 20 to 25
minutes covering a lot more information
than we covered here and yeah
i will catch you all later
peace